Assassin's Creed has always been about
history from the first games medieval
Crusades setting to the Victorian London
of Assassin's Creed syndicate ubisoft's
long-running stealth and stabbing series
has allowed players to visit and explore
key times in human history Assassin's
Creed origins is doubling down on this
with the introduction of discovery mode
a combat free no time limit exploration
mode of ancient Egypt that will offer
dozens of guided tours to help players
better understand ancient Egypt but that
still months off so I'm here to give you
a crash course in ancient Egypt with the
help of Assassin's Creed's franchise
historian max your and oh and I guess
some of this could be considered
spoilers but remember Assassin's Creed
origins is the story of by yak and
there's no specific details of that part
of the narrative
and it's specific to the time period of
Cleopatra our ascension to the throne is
that it's very rich geopolitically you
have both landmarks from ancient Egypt
the pyramids the villages the city of
Memphis the first capital so very very
old stuff all the culture that's bring
brought within these villages and then
at the same time you have a Greek
Macedonian Pharaoh
so Cleopatra her brother and husband
Ptolemy the 13th
it's very rich it's very complex for us
it creates an opportunity to tell a
story about assassins and Templar
Assassin's Creed origins is set during
the reign of Ptolemy xiii around 49 247
BC most significantly the story of byuk
takes place in front of the backdrop of
Cleopatra's rise to the throne the
Ptolemaic Kingdom lasted in ancient
Egypt from 305 BC to 30 BC and kicked
off with the death of Alexander the
Great in 323 BC and the Ascension of
Ptolemy the first to the role of Pharaoh
what was very important for us from the
bat was that byuk needed to be centered
around this country yet he had this
vision of the country that was
legitimate so we knew that we wanted to
invest a lot into the quest system being
able to talk with anybody in the country
to to help people and so in that process
we look into all the different
possibilities of the kind of role that
he could have at that moment measures
are very old at the moment of byuk they
are at first automatic tribe from the
south of Egypt that were mercenaries for
the Pharaoh and then they moved up north
with the centuries they intermarried and
they're their nationality got lost but
the title of Magi stayed in ancient
Egypt and become associated as
protectors of the people as protectors
of the Pharaoh the ptolemies adopted
many Egyptian cultural staples in order
to cement their place with the native
populace an Egyptian custom adopted by
the Ptolemies was the wedding of
siblings in 51 BC Cleopatra the seventh
rose to power at the age of eighteen
after the death of her father Ptolemy
the 12th alongside her husband and
brother 10 year-old Ptolemy the
thirteenth he's he's a very young youth
he's probably 14 at the time of the
beginning of the game and so he's very
manipulative
I Cleopatra tries to set him off aside
she stops writing his name on the Artic
under Stellar's of the arraylist ella so
she tries to keep the power for herself
and that doesn't work very well she gets
mobbed by people in Alexandria she get
exiled by play mice and advisors
counselors like putnis as Ptolemy was
underage when the siblings took power
haughtiness was appointed as his Regent
cotta misused his influence over the
younger sibling to sow contempt and turn
told me the 13th against his sister in
48 BC the two enacted a plan to depose
Cleopatra and install Ptolemy as a ruler
with Potamus working behind the scenes
the civil war that resulted forced
Cleopatra into exile as Ptolemy the
thirteenth became sole ruler of Egypt
speaking of civil war something similar
was going on at the time over in ancient
Greece a civil war had been raging
between Julius Caesar and his supporters
and the conservative Optimates who were
supported by Pompey and his legions
several battles raged with each general
experiencing bitter defeat and
hard-fought victories but after the
Battle of for solace where Caesar
secured a decisive victory
Pompey fled to Egypt where he begged the
new Pharaoh for asylum seeing an
opportunity to curry favor with the
up-and-coming Julius Caesar Ptolemy and
potenuse accepted Pompey into their
Kingdom the welcome was a ploy however
as Pompey was murdered and beheaded as
his wife and children watched plotting
his plan was to present Pompey's head to
Caesar and reap the rewards the New
Kingdom was sure to receive for dealing
with this enemy what they didn't know
was that Caesar had been merciful to his
enemies and when he arrived in
Alexandria he was disgusted by the
presentation of Pompey's head
he ordered Pompey's body be returned to
Greece so he could be given a proper
Roman funeral he seized the Egyptian
capital and installed himself as arbiter
between the rival siblings seeing her
chance Cleopatra had herself smuggled
into the palace in a rolled-up carpet to
speak with Caesar the two quickly became
lovers and she gave birth to their son
Ptolemy Caesar in 47 BC Caesar no longer
wishing to play both sides threw his
support completely behind his mistress
unfortunately Caesar was besieged in the
Egyptian capital of Alexandria and was
finally freed when his request for
assistance was answered by method
deities and his army Caesar then led his
army against Ptolemy at the Battle of
the Nile where he was ultimately
triumphant at the age of 15 Ptolemy xiii
allegedly drowned in the Nile
after his retreating ship capsized
Cleopatra was again appointed to the
throne until her death in 30 BC after
which Egypt became part of the Roman
Empire so that's the cliffnotes of one
of the most interesting and politically
charged times in ancient Egyptian
history if you're interested in more
Assassin's Creed origins be sure to
check out our review and the wealth of
guides articles and gameplay videos
we're all producing for you here at
GameSpot as always do let me know your
thoughts on this video you can find me
on twitter at it's dan crowd or just
leave me a comment below thanks for
watching
[Music]